[Music]
it's 12 o'clock you're watching Sky News
as the salute is made
[Music]
as they curl ice into the sky very much
as they did in the dog fights it was
always said that Goering and the
Luftwaffe of Germany used to find the
dexterity and speed of these excellent
fighting aircraft but what made it so
impossible for the Germans to gain air
superiority and it was during all that
fighting that Dame Vera played her part
in maintaining the morale of the nation
today she will have her funeral with her
family and we've already seen the family
of all gathered in the town itself along
with her daughter Virginia Lewis Jones
and the whole village have come out to
mark this and wherever you are
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
born in 1917 Dame Vera started her
service to the nation in the underground
stations at the beginning of the Second
World War when everyone used them as
air-raid shelters from the Blitz of the
Luftwaffe of course it was the Battle of
Britain that helped to curtail to some
degree the effect of those raids and we
remember the effect of these aircraft in
that the evocative sound of the Spitfire
the regimental sergeant major
[Applause]
you first Battalion Coldstream Guards
with the troops as they now fly away and
the affection of everyone is expressed
[Applause]